we are of course in the product that is so coveted on the
Christmas tree Q4
we are lucky because we are
always the most emotional ones because in the end
what does your grandma want I want the photos
of your grandchildren and whatever
she wants the calendar that she has somehow
been getting for years  Photo book that means
we have of course an extreme
steel because of the product we
have but in summer if you are furnishing a
new apartment or something like that
then the couch is more important than the
picture behind it then the wall
stays white for the time being welcome  to the OMR
podcast today a hidden champion was a
guest with whom I just found out in the preliminary
talk, but we have mutual
acquaintances who would have thought it,
greetings to Essen at least someone who
has stopped an extremely large company
and is not yet well known to the
public  welcome moin hi you made my
poster yes and
always started without investors a  lso
really out of nowhere a
company that is really big now we
have to understand how
you got there but in the meantime
poster we are talking about companies with 100
million sentences exactly we wanted to make 100
million this year make this
year not quite because there  Are
you doing a bit of a slump?
eCommerce is moderate but we're scratching it
and how do you get there I mean the
topic so you sell prints of all kinds
you can say no so that's a
market that already exists or have
n't you reinvented it but how does it work  it
was off we went via detours i think
many entrepreneurs start via detours
i have i have never
worked anywhere my my wife has always been
very good i would have had a little
more structure i studied in
Bruchsal near
Karlsruhe at the time it didn’t exist either  more the
university went bankrupt okay I still thought it was
really good and then I went to university
right after
that  I then set up my own business
immediately afterwards and then, like
I actually did, I took the
pictures, so to speak, I thought, okay, where
are the big Maren in it and then I came
up with pictures like oil paintings and
then I started in 2000 that was in 2006 in 2007
I flew to Asia to  Consul back
then at this big trade fair
and I founded it together with my brother
, so right at the very
beginning it was called RM REK was a registered
businessman making the first mistake and
then we just
flew to Hongkong and then to Konsum and then over
to the Chinese and we met  Bought a
container and
imagine a container of oil paintings
a bit, although we simply repainted
old masters and
we ordered them, yes, then it did
n’t matter, or yes, the Chinese had the motifs
on site, they were just these
old masters repainted van Goghs or
repainted sunsets or something like that
Tuscany so everything you
don't really want these whole kits  ch
and we then imported it and
then sold it to whom, yes, we
didn't think about it back then, so how
we'd sell them, we weren't that far
yet, we have today you would
say pop-up stores, we
just had me back then  I'm from
Saarland and in Saarbrücken I just
rented a store, an
empty space, so I
put things in there with an
easel, I put it in myself
to sell to people who
walked in there okay so we're talking about
the year 200 years 2007 2008 differently
but the idea of ​​flying to China now, so
to speak, and somehow
buying copied pictures is
so stupid in hindsight yes it's totally
stupid but  It was then I think
as an entrepreneur it's like that I wanted to
be independent somehow I thought it would be
okay  somehow it
works we flew there
and heard something good margins because customers have
good well we have back then
you have to say we bought them I
'd guess in the 80s depending on the size
no we can't get the biggest usually
between 80 and 90 dollar cents then you have it
still import costs and all the
container costs and so well
logistics costs there were also
no idea two three dollars but you
had it at the end of the
day I had it in my
parents basement for three three and a half dollars yes
and then I put it in
I can tell you how I sold it in this shop at the time
, but I would guess I
sold it directly to the end
customer that
was definitely for 100 € or 119 euros
that was definitely a good one
if someone bought it that was
the problem is that's
how we started and it
didn't go so well actually in these
shops I thought at first that it was
Saarbrücken  n I said come on,
experience something in Berlin and once again
in another city but that
didn't work either, so I thought okay the motives
I was relatively convinced of this
routine then I thought they have to be there
somehow then we have to
find another distribution channel and
then we said okay let's
start trading and then
after we actually slog after these pop-up stores
that was really
a that was a hard time because in
the end you just have 18 hours
in this store  stood and didn't
sell anything and didn't sell anything okay and you
didn't have a podcast to listen to back
then, what was that
but okay that means then going into a
trade means which
retail chain at that time had such a Golf such a
Golf 4 from my parents and
then I'm first  drove around so
I then did that at the time I was
still doing it in Saarland well my
brother then we
moved to Munich my friend  n
was in Munich today and
then we'll see Munich and then I
just got out of the car, I
drove into furniture stores or something like that at the
beginning you don't go to such big
chains but just like that in every
city or in front of every city  yes, always
these big furniture stores, be it
a Segmüller or a Porter or, depending
on the region, he has different ones and
even then you start with the small
furniture stores or
furniture stores because I went in here, had
all the pictures in the trunk
and I put them under my arm
and I’m there  went in and tried to
sell it and that was
but that's I think it was right away that was
hard but what was successful that was
successful define successful but it
was successful so it was for once
it was definitely hard was of course
great for which I also thrown outside
I mean, you can imagine
I drove into the parking lot, but I had a customer in this store, I'm purely
theoretical  I mean you are someone who
buys here I have awesome goods
and um that went surprisingly well
really the whole hard school yes it
went surprisingly well um I
always have a rule of thumb that if
I get kicked out five times then
I have  stopped on that day, I
really thought at some point, okay, uh,
so at some point you almost get
depressed, no, and then I
kind of had the rule, okay, after being thrown out five times a
day, I also
stopped, but I actually
wobbled through the republic with this one
Golf and I tried to sell
it and it went well, so in the
beginning she only had the small
furniture stores, do you have it normally
? I put it
together and sold it for 400
euros  Package 300 euros or so
or sometimes you just
gave it away to say try it
out and if she sells it call me
u  and then you gradually
go to the big furniture stores
that takes time but it also took
me a while until you got an appointment like that
or that you came to
the journey I’m actually exactly
you don’t know anymore but in that
I think the first year was like
120,000 euros out of the car in the
second year we were already so far 350
400 that was already back then I thought it was the
case for me the world is always the case
with the margin is for you then
even if you  so good so would have continued
with the Lord would have been better with
me more that we
no but and then it's our turn to the
larger chains we have
to get a daring listing, so to speak, because
the usual suspects xxlutz Porter
then we also had hardware stores
hagebau  a listing
Hornbach we had a listing then we had
a big listing
in Switzerland a few minutes yes that
was the case then we almost had it in
2008 I think  In 2009, 200
million sales, two and a half, the
only problem was that somehow it wasn't that
well thought out because the business model because
we had to pre-finance the goods because
the Chinese wanted to be financed
, uh, when do I have to pay beforehand and the
furniture stores have super long
payment terms
and that's how we had it  actually no cash
that was actually our main topic
Chinese people then really
painted these pictures really cool
or will it be painted cool I
just picked out pictures again because
I somehow
wanted to remember the time I was there and
that  it's crazy you have to imagine it
like when you went in, even then in
a normal house, not
in the factory but in the house
you went in, then the teacher hung
white wine canvases on the wall and
then the sample picture hung, so what did
I have before  ordered I had no
idea what I was selling that means I
'm actually b  I googled Toscana
picture I pulled some picture and sent it to the
Chinese that was then I
thought okay
old masters it looked exactly if you are
an old master please well then you can
just say from God then have yourself
pulled it myself
and didn't now imitate it by hand with oil
that was really it was also
really good because there was no it was
okay in terms of quality okay and how did you
then solve the interim
financing problem
not at all by me by going online
so we  then said
okay somehow we have to solve this problem
when there were actually two
problems with the business model
one was the liquidity problems
because we simply cannot grow due to these long
payment terms you actually
had to pre-finance every growth somehow you
always had the wrong one  Motifs in stock
that means you had this whole
wrong stick the d  u also had to
get rid of them first and you had and
the problem was that the bigger you
actually got, the higher the
pressure from retail became, so retail
then at some point really started
to push in the RWZ, i.e.
advertising cost contributions or they once said
you only get new ones  Listings if
you
are involved in such and such houses, so to speak,
and such people have such topics,
that means I on the one hand
we actually didn't
really feel like an entrepreneur anymore
because you actually got it from the
handshake and on the other
hand  Wasn't it actually a good business model when you looked at your cash,
it was good in terms of
growth and the margin was theoretically
good on paper, but you've got it, but
at that moment
you can let it run out, you'll get
the last claims transferred, yes
then  then with let's say 200
million sales 2 million or two
exactly two two egg  nhalb the margin
it almost doesn't matter, then you earned the first
million with it, yes, we
made exactly back then, we then made it,
it's always relatively entrepreneurs, there are
and we just
decided on two new
pictures, we actually like the
type from the  Bring us a model and let's do
something online and then we'll
deal with the thinking like that,
no, we said okay, let's just move away from the path from
retail to e-commerce that was
actually the idea that was the mindset back
then and then we said in 2009  we
build up eCommerce and let the
trade run for so long that we
continue to have sales, so to speak, and then in
2009, 2010, we founded Microsoft,
who then programmed for a relatively long time,
a year a little longer
to
more or less crowdsource motifs,
so they no longer buy your motifs
but instead  People had
the issue that we had the wrong motives together, that is, we
actually wanted the problem to go
away  if we remain a picture then
let's do it in such a way that the customer
brings the content because then it's up to
us we have to have one
less problem in the chain but
you really came up with that initially
you mean there's
mine  Snapfish is the name of one of those there's
kind of my photo book so I think
there's a whole middle one there's CEWE
COLOR I think so I have
n't quite researched the market but I knew
or already know in the last few years of
course something like that was also completely given away as a gift
somehow
Christmas parties somewhere that  we're
already doing a few things it was like that back
then yes that was back then I think as an
entrepreneur you don't see the competition there, you don't see the
competition like that nay
, somehow I'll start
wars back then there definitely
were our main competitors who
are still there  there were already positive XL back
then I think there are two
I can't say 26 started
CEWE g  from anyway clear and then there
was another company that bought them
again bought positive XL back
then the post Jackson closed you
and the Americans
the Americans were
n’t that present in our market back then, so to speak,
we didn’t notice it that way and it was from
Market environment still different I mean it was
2829 20 and 2 22 so
somehow everything was still possible Customer acquisition
was probably also extremely relaxed
because you were somehow just right with Google
SEO was still different very
different was, so to speak, a
different world back then, nonetheless more
I think we started with one
order a day so I think
we always have an order if we
didn't have one I ordered
we always had an order for
it made it filmed we
then decided back in 2009 that
we would
also print ourselves in addition to importing
At that time,
my brother and I had the printer in our office
bought back then I still know two hell of a
lot of money for 5000 € such a printer and
then we were already printing, so to speak,
and probably filming it, so when
we only started with murals back
then, not with the
huge range but with a small
range of canvas posters all
we kind of printed that and that ourselves
and then we had the other
article someone actually has it
we were lucky because there was
a print shop across the street
and then we always
drove over with a pallet, so to speak, they had
it  printed for us so drove back with the
pallet with a
lizard like that over the curb and
we missed that so we missed
that I left but in the
end it was also a print or photos or what did you
produce up front like mugs or
it  there is everything no we
started with just normal
canvas pictures canvas pictures posters
and that's it u  And then successive
products were added. Today you print
on a lot of materials, you can also
print acrylic glass, print aluminum, of
course you can say calendars
Your
photo in large is wall pictures,
so to speak, there is everything that can be hung on the wall,
so poster, canvas, frame, so
Diba and acrylic glass, then we have
photo books, then we have calendars,
then we have cards, greeting cards, months,
then we have
photos, so normal photo prints,
then we have  another product that means
picture boxes that also have feed trains
in them exactly and then we sell
other motifs at myposter ourselves but that’s a totally
small market okay
the idea that you buy existing motifs from
you is actually out
but it  really gives
a print forever more or less
now you can say yes we would u  ns
won't designate either, I
always say you have to print you can, so we
have two production facilities near
Munich, one in Dachau, an exact roof
on the one in Munich and one in
Saxony-Anhalt, but in the end
we write software, in the end it's
for us, so to speak  the most important thing is that the customers
you have a blatant pain I
mean the pain of designing a photo book
is so damn everyone
who has done it now knows that you
don't really feel
like starting it but you want to do it because you know like your
mom  is happy or your grandmother yes that
means this this pain yes you can
only
beat it with software that means we started super early
so we could distinguish ourselves from the
competition in trying to beat
everything with software we wrote
the software ourselves from the start
and today we're writing
all these configurators for everything
to do with the products themselves and the printing, yes, we
're very good at it  n the
productions are super, we also get an
incredible amount of goods out
and we have a super
production disruption software that enables us
to get through this lot size 1 more
efficiently is not that
easy because it's all loose size 1 that's where
we differ from the
flyer alarm or from one  from
which my print or so to speak yes they
print flyers or everything above water
but we go size 1 we print your
motif once your holiday picture exactly and
and that just has to fit because you forgive
us the value chain
we have two partners in the
whole high season where we
simply get more incoming orders than
we can work away, so we have
two more partners involved
who only do something very special, for example
with photo books, a special type
otherwise we do everything ourselves and you
have until today I said
everything too  self-financed yes up to
now we have financed everything ourselves we
have al  the machines and so of course there
are machine leasings on it but we
don't have any venture capital in it.
People work for the company at the
moment
give a bit of
capital or didn't you ever want
no we never
wanted we people ask this yes but
we haven't
accepted that until now that's for me but
you do it to your brother your wife
i think so too no exactly yes and  It
actually works really well,
so I have to say I'm sitting here alone now,
but without my brother or without
my wife it was impossible to get
here, but if you do a
little research then there are
stories that you bought it the hard way,
so I think  there
are several cases of sudden hearing loss and
herniated discs and the journey,
which of course now sounds awesome  but
simply super is
entrepreneurial has also been
a hard road for you yes I think I
had at that time in the two 13 14
15 times the poster was super small still
the trade we had to continue the trade in
the end because it brought in a
bit of sales  and
then of course it also
brought volume and we need
volume in the productions, I have to
imagine that the most difficult thing was
actually that we tried to build up the
online business with, so to speak, a
quite capital-intensive production
these machines are all it
's not a snap you buy there
you  then you need space and you have
a completely different type of person
we always fought on two fronts
and at that time when we still had the trade
and myposter tried to
get away from the trade so that was the
way it was and they didn’t have one either  Turnover
made now I think in the first year
the times prostat made a good
million or s  o and she made
two in 48 always doubled a bit more
I think the first few years
as well not that difficult at the level
and
it was just a hard time I
think you
have a dream like an entrepreneur and then you move  it through
there you don’t have any so I had
no respect from my body and
then from time to time I banged yes I
had there yes I was exactly
mad okay
you always sailed close to the wind because
the money that you have now somehow had
to convert  you are directly
invested again in order to be able to grow
yes always close to the wind
with joy actually with bank loans
then or always from the cash flow who took
forever until we had bank loans
we have I think I also have my
first credit card who has
almost six  seven years I just got a little
credit card from the bank
before I was even considered creditworthy
it must have taken 25 16 until I got
my credit card  e we
did
it until
2000, until we actually bought university
, we did it without any bank
loans, it's actually
so common in the segment, I think we haven't
really covered it here in the podcast in the last few years
and it
's yours  Then there are some
cool XXL posters, there are some sort of
flyer alarms, they
really aren’t confirmed right away, but
there are also big companies working in the same
environment and extremely large companies
are all the owners who made
them themselves, no, we are, um, so we are  we
are the last one as far as I know that has
no matcha capital or
private equity or anything in it, so to speak,
the others have usually already been
sold twice or have
already given up the majority, so
at least we are them from what is known in
the industry
the only ones left are XXL, for
example, it was a super long
birthday before I sold them,
ok  y and that is
and it is, let's say, the use of
materials is probably
not that much higher now than it was back then with
the Chinese
products, or I mean if you think about it now
, how do you know the mathematics
so what costs what for you if I
have one with you now  Order a photo calendar like
that what does it cost? An
annual calendar like that depends on which
paper you choose, but
if you say you want to send or finishing, then it
costs between 20 and 24 euros in the A4 on the wall
and production is
probably still
the 3  € or so yes exactly that means large
amounts as before yes but now high
marketing out where
marketing expenses so exactly you have of course you have to feed
your machine
park that is not
so you can count on second material
but at the end of the day you have
you have a production that runs all year round
, that means
you can actually cause it all year round
cost and you have this hot this
calendar for example good example
you really only sell in six
weeks in July you don’t want a calendar what
do you do with your sales if 100
million do you make half
yes 30 percent or something like Q4 so 30
Percent then exactly because yes okay
not distributed Q4 but only if you December
then okay okay
the entire machine park depreciation
utilization that the problem is not a
problem but it is definitely a
challenge so you
just have to take that into account when you
say now a calendar costs  3 € paper
costs maybe 1 2 € staff
on top of that and then depreciation of machines
and such but they just don't run in the summer
no you have to see
how you do that in the summer
we went into different
business models we did
n't just have  the myposter, we have
other companies who, so to speak,
print everything that we do on the subject of printing or on demand
actually a little bit
of looking at company that
sells greeting cards christmas cards
wedding cards can love and that's
great for example in spring and
summer
that we found that i founded
so in the same
group that we founded that went to
town last year  in January
or full in December
it's okay and we have but in the end
marketing is probably still an issue because what was
so easy at the beginning because Google was
simply SEO and sia was cheaper
if I imagine right now in
the research  looking at your
keyword you are of course also uh
Poster XXL you notice there is of course
competition the keywords are
somehow neither of them print calendars
or print photos then I suspect that it
probably costs
a few euros somehow by now,
yes, exactly me  think that's something good
times bad ne we are totally addicted
get  riebener market that means we have
at least the search queries that also helps
marketing that
you somehow don’t have to run after them
but you already have them there so
the electricity is already there and then
there are extremely high click costs,
so you actually have to look
that you convert, so we also say
something at the end of the conversion game, you
just have to see that it converts really well
and then you have
different products where you have very
good repurchase rates, e.g.
a photo book that you actually bought here
, a calendar is bought annually
then you have a topic like photo prints
many people do every six weeks
or eight weeks exactly
although we are not really good
at CRM I would say we can be
better or we are working
on it but luckily we have customers who do
that then  for us they
come back okay in the end because when
you hear about 100 million sales
now I guess ma  l don't manage ten percent
that you could do it, yes, but you
invest it is invested we have,
so to speak, we have always invested a little
bit in software many
new business models, if you just
, of course, we always have a lot of
employees so that we, so to speak
, it takes effect  sometimes from the
new pool or from the old pool, that
means we make sure that we are
always well strengthened so that when
new challenges come that we
get but yes you could do
it of course but that’s over you could
do it but well  that's probably or 20
percent, I think if you
look at our competition, then it's also
possible, yes, the public one there,
you can see that, you see or something, that's
halfway public, partly okay, wow,
that was somehow then at the
sales level, it's already attractive then  yes
and but all my flyers have changed
from time to time that the somehow
perimeter advertising S  port sponsoring or
doing things like that but it
doesn't matter we don't do everything we
have in the marketing mix we
also have we did TV advertising last year this
year
around this whole topic spasm
over so around this whole
software topic at  It's easy
for us to create a photo book no, that's the topic,
but no, bandenberg and there we are at the
end we are and flyeralarm is
already much bigger than we are
maybe it does a lot more
now don't know but in any case
it's a lot bigger that means they
have a
completely different spending than we do that means
80% of your marketing goes into Google
yes
and then  a bit of TV
testing here and there is a TV
Youtube display the usual channels
influencer works well for us too
y because we are clear we are now so
we now have all these we cover
yes
ideal for birth or wedding or Aldi
topics ne and there you have of course
influida fully go in the whole
Christmas theme Christmas gifts is
perfect for influenza so we don't
already have our influenza games  so
bad and there we have
we see good numbers and you have
started to start
your own business or
let's say a
utilization signal
meaningful you have to say but you're also buying
now so I kind of read one too
another salad four unique or
unique was known because in the start-up
scene it was always discussed yes
, then I don’t think it went
so well in Corona either and you struck,
yes we did exactly that, we
actually bought two companies last year,
we have a small one
Bought a company in France called Art
Foto limited, we do it that way, it's
actually really cool then  we're
trying to do it, we're actually trying to have the epic
photo, so we have this John
F Kennedy photo and it has
a license with Live Magazine, for example, the
only printer that has
that means we're trying to do this screen
photo, so every photo what if you have one
Band or a person thinks that is in front of
you or the Steve McQueen photo with the
pistol we have that in there the
sale yes exactly so we always have
this epic photo that is the idea of ​​the
company we bought a very small
company in France and
this  very cool and then we just
last year
so exactly in November we
haven't bought the biscuit here in Corona
well we were fine too but how were
they available then you have the
feeling
we got a good deal you
heard yes  my observation outside was
actually totally because a
lot of money flowed in, no, that's
these new
29 minutes
[laughter],
so we're one  When a good deal
arrived, we
have always had contact with the founders or have had contact for a long time
. We also do
further production in the productions, which
means we do not produce for ourselves,
but we still have we make
sure that we always produce for third parties
, so we produce
actually also for our competitors
and unique at the time they were
founded, they came to us I
think they had a different printer before
and then asked us if
we could produce for them and the prints there
are somehow motifs that you
can exactly do yourself  they have curated
artists, that is, in the end, curated
motifs that they sell on the Unicom on the platform, so to speak,
and
then they sell it, and because we
started printing for them super early on
, we actually had a really good
relationship, nonetheless, it
went over
via an MMA process
and then a standard process with all the
trimmings  but then in the end we have to
pay a bit
because you haven't paid either, no,
we weren't the only ones,
so we wanted to have more, okay, yes,
it was a decent process, which
makes sense for you, too, when it comes to
capacity utilization  to have
that for us we have with it what is up
front so exactly on the one hand it
was good for the utilization you have to
say in the end they sell quite
a lot but we have we are
at the myposter extremely performance
driven and we don’t really have any
like that  had a real creative streak
somewhere and we wanted our idea was
that we build a marketplace
and we had said okay, do
we want to start with it now or maybe we can find
something that we have
where we have a super good starting point
and since the university is going to be creative  Or
then there were already a lot of artists, as
I said, okay, the name is actually ideal for us,
which is also good, yes,
ic  h tell me then the brand is also
pretty good from that so relatively
grad that actually means great
and then uh have exactly
the plan is that we
actually want to achieve a personalized
one the idea is that we
would open this whole creator community on the one hand that  we will
open it we will so we just
started programming so already
at the beginning of the year and we even need
Q1 Q2 until next year or something like that when we go live until
we kind of have our softwarekend in
there that we want and the idea is
that we have a  complete creator
community on the left, i.e.
on the seller page, you
have artists as well as all the
sellers who are now on Etsy or
who are on shopify everything if you have
no idea who has designed
a cool t-shirt or something
a sold shopify shop and the
problem at the moment with
all these marketplaces is that they don't
fulfill and you  can't
personalize it, so if
you've personalized it on Etsy, you
end up with this small
personalization field, you have to
write it in somehow,
my name is Philipp, please write it
on the t-shirt, if you
want it somewhere and then you'll get it,
so to speak  from the seller who
then edits it in Photoshop
and sends it to you and then you say yes it
fits and we actually want to
take away this pain plus that the
artist at the moment the Etsy seller also has
to be full of films that's how we came up with
it, so to speak  we
noticed in the waldlevel productions
that we hear a lot of shopify got it
themselves who had
individual products
produced by us and then
sent them to their home, then
packed them and then sent them to you when
you ordered and now we're leaving  back
and say okay we're building a platform
where you can do all these creative creators
the whole  n seller can design the products up front
, so we make
sure that we have a crazy number of products up front
, so not just murals but
the whole gladiator everything you like
now I'll say a
baby pillow where you somehow put
your child's name on it  write that as a
gift or also a t-shirt as
apparel or stationery or
whatever you can imagine
gift tags but everything that you can
somehow creatively design
and that you as a Bavarian then just use the
normal configurator because they are
just so good  inside
you can design this whole product and
we also do the full filming for you,
that means we
actually take the Ötzi seller, the
seller who is already selling on
etc. we actually give him a much
easier process because he has to
on the one hand we no longer personalize the thing ourselves
and on the other hand
we do so much with a lot  and as
what we have in form
okay well and what you just bought in France
you are also already
set up throughout Europe or so far depending
on the company exactly so in at
unique we do almost all European
[music]
countries at myposter we copy
everything  South to north times when I'm a lot
so if you don't have England there and no
Scandinavia so smaller the big or
is a good question I ask ourselves
every year why if they aren't
in England we're just not at the
moment we've had enough  do with
with with roof and also with my poster
makes Italy out of Spain
and I actually had enough to
do there because there were enough growth opportunities and you
know it so you have to have every
language or every currency has a
certain complexity and then again
you have  now that brexit is no
longer so attractive for the UK to send, that
means you actually have a
few logistics issues there and because
we are up there now  n also have no
production so in in UK where do you want
to go with that I mean if you hear it like that
Corona has now also increased that has
just been indicated you can
imagine people finally giving the
hardware stores the right apartment again
or their basement rooms and  then you go
to you and have
something nice printed or something nice designed
in the way, so one day I’ll go
public or wait until it’s even bigger
and then call projects again
or good question I think you’re
getting along there  always his thoughts I do
n't have any yet
I think we look at each other from time
to time and say okay it's in the
constellation in which we do
it that we can still, so to speak, achieve the growth
or the goals that we
intend and I think as long as we do
as long as we enjoy it and as long
as we don't get any issues here we
would actually like to do it
in our core business but we ca
n't do it because wi  r no cache yes I think
we'll do it like this for now
everything of course yes I think every
entrepreneur knows that you too that's
just cool if you can make your own
decision it
's just good if you know okay
there are three of you sitting at the table  and you
can do what you say and you do
n't have to ask a fourth question and I think
as long as you can maintain the status quo there
is growth because everything doubles right at the
beginning if you
say a million what is what this year so
you can get there at short notice  200 or in the
short term is always relative, so
you definitely get to 200, that's
definitely not the issue, you
have to be patient, I
think every business model per se is
growing really well, so the
core businesses are also growing well, even
in comparison  now for the Corona yes get
so last year we also
get growth again something cool we
also see very proud of
it  so yes we have and especially
what we have with the Nico from the
marketplace model we
don't see any problems that we can't
grow through even with the maibos
adults strong as I said in our
small business
can be okay and with the small companies
always 100  % or 120%.  one can
love or a kind of photo limited what
so to speak smaller than there Change
is still strong and how are you
affected by the whole thing or what
is your impression of
supply chains I mean who would also have to
buy the materials
is it really like that  People are now
actually buying less from you because of the inflation,
because they say somehow these are the
things that you can no longer afford
, maybe how do you feel
that, well, we actually had
really gone downhill with us from the beginning of the Ukraine war
we were also really worried so we
had April was then really I
think the fire minus 30 - 35 May
also purchase restraint nothing more
but I think it was the same with everyone so
I think if you
've read all the reports  by Zalando
or built or something
like that and then we
started
or we own it  It actually started in the
summer that we said okay,
we’re going to focus a bit more
on shorter campaigns to make them
more attractive in price, that
actually worked really well and
then it’s tightened again, so it’s
actually always been eight to
ten weeks  really good
again also extremely strong growth again to the fire
[music]
we are definitely above the
market level so we are also from the
data I think we are simply
good
but so price action at the end no we
'll see that we can of course prices
so from  From the customer's point of view, they have extremely good
prices, but if
we logically monitor our
basket cases and the the the
the the the the the construction and that
's we see that it's stable
exactly where we have problems for
shopping so if you look at the
raw materials are relative
strong
[music]
in the self-propelled that means we
do manufacture together already the
same  r no, we just buy
rodable wood or we buy
huge sheets of aluminum
or acrylic glass and then we use them to create
individual images that are milled outside,
that's pretty cool when you
've seen it when we make this picture
and it's gotten more expensive  on
average at the moment almost
12 percent across all materials, 12 to 14
percent is really heavy and that hits
us really hard and then of
course inflation in
general also hits you, because of course you have
price adjustments or because the
employees
have higher salary demands, so to speak, you know that
I'm sure they'll come right
away
, no, definitely not
, I don't think so, and yes, I think you just have to
be more efficient,
you can't pass it on at the moment, that's how we
try to keep the price stable for the customer,
that's the way it is
and it's trendy right now  such a time when
the reluctance starts you
just don't get that much more for your pro  duct
and we are honestly
now things are getting better so of course we are already
in the
product that is so coveted on the Christmas tree Q4 we are lucky
because we are always the most emotional
thing because in the end what does your grandma want I want
the photos of your grandchildren and
whatever about the calendar she
's been getting for years, the
photo book, that means we have
an extremely strong one, of course, we're
strong because of the product we have,
but in the summer, if you're going
to set up a new apartment or something like that, then
it's the couch  more important than the picture
behind it then the wall
stays white for now yes but you need a
couch and I read at your
house there are no pictures hanging
there no pictures really do
n't no no I don't know why I
really don't have any pictures hanging there  Only
I still have only gray walls without green without
red as I wanted to change but
I have to change it with some original
I have to  my gallery or something
yes I know that but
I have to do one exactly I have to mean
one dream is somehow my
gallery walk into it and that's it and that's
how I start
but somehow I have
n't found one yet and I can just do it now
not regularly yes you have to go
to Johann König who also
contacted ah because they had asked
if we could produce for the collections he
definitely has but
also extremely expensive yes expensive
I would be attractive I am sure
he would explain to you  that it's
worth a lot more in a few years yes yes yes
I'll come back next time in Berlin
okay um well that
means no precise plans on how to
proceed it's going to
continue for the time being anyway so we
have we have that yes  structured in such a way
that we had different GmbH
GmbHs that are managed individually by
the managing director.
I still manage the malposter with me  a woman together
and we see that they
grow strongly for themselves and then we look at each
other, so to speak, in the segment
with a myposter, we then look at each other
clearly okay are there markets in which
we can grow or do we add
something else to that  yes until now
you could also say again we are going
outside now we can also
go to a textiles or something like that we have
this whole thing to do with textiles that means
everything you can personalize
in the pillow area or something like that is also
huge markets there you could  let's go in we'll take a
look at other countries we'll take a look too
ok we can go to
the pond the Americans
have a huge market of course that means
we'll take a look but there are some
of these companies
that do something like that really at home but that's there  if you had
no respect for respect for
I think that helps me in the end I
have since I always have a pretty good one
but it's still a business  ss
for an
execution excellence yes there were comes
hear me uh so in marketing I
can imagine you have to do very good
online marketing to somehow
get through there and in logistics or
production you also imagine
that somehow if it
comes up  it's also very strong in total,
so if you we have the production,
I don't manage it either, my
wife managed it now we also have
an external manager in there, but she
's still great after that, and that's exactly what it
is in the end, you have to get out of it insane
be efficient I mean you also
have perso costs you have 20
Übertrelle and of course there is a lot
going on so we manufacture one of
these can't say exactly the number right now but logically we
will already manufacture a few thousand articles
Production yes
definitely more than 10,000  on the day yes on the
day okay
exactly don't manufacture articles and that's
where efficiency
comes in, it depends on processes
it's a completely different business, so to speak, than it
is at the front of the portfolio and
we're super strong there and I
think this whole thing only
worked because we in this constellation of three of
a brand and I in
these initial areas support
each other completely  trusted and
then everyone could do their own thing, no,
I always made Microsoft, the
new business models my wife has and they
are both very entrepreneurial,
that means here we all have similar
ways of thinking or the same ways of thinking and
so we were able to have one at all
Then let production grow in the end
and not without so I
could now also without without let’s say
investments in the USA
build them up individually then immediately ah good
question
we don’t know exactly how
we’re going to look we’re probably
looking at that right there you could  if you had to set up
a production in an emergency
, we've done that before
in Sac  hsen-Anhalt has also become a
second production, which means you
would have some experience, but we wo
n't do it
tomorrow we'll look at who
produced where we could, so to speak
, we have a common match that we,
so to speak, don't live with the whole, for
example, not with the whole portfolio
go but um but
let's take a selective look at it makes sense does
n't it make any sense but we're
just looking at it no that hasn't been decided yet
maybe it makes more sense that
we add the vertical because it's
simply easier or costs are
called vertical  then somehow, for
example, textiles or something like that,
just say, come on, let's
just add textiles and then
you suddenly have a huge market and you
already have existing players,
but because on the one hand we naturally have
a large customer group and on the
other hand we can help  we
really do a lot about configurators,
so software is yes  always like this the
picture is uploaded what do you do with
this picture how how well do you get a
collage displayed online so nowadays
everything is based on your own browser also
photo book that’s already your processes
so with us it will be that because
idea you uploaded in the week
to  to 8 million photos a week, so to speak,
that go up there and the customers
then I think the record was
looked at once in a photo book someone
had 2200 pictures
from this brand browser in it and then
he just starts, like a
Photoshop he starts
to do trimming that means in the end
it's not so that's not trivial
to write this software for it so
say okay if we go into textiles now
we have this core of
course we can't produce it but in
the end it's for us  Is the way there no
longer so difficult? I
just asked what is the
value of a company and somehow switched to
maltepilz  aut there are few because
at least i haven't found any companies listed on the stock exchange
i thought of christoph behn or far from here from kartenmacherei and he sold it no i think it was
rumored he didn't want to tell me
like most of them just hinted
at so i have like 100 million  heard out
and in terms of sales of
sales they didn't I don't
know I've only heard the 100
million or up to I don't know
but that's definitely a
Maltepudel I think I was sort of on
it so that means you'll
definitely be the  Definitely films with
you now, let's say
well over 100 million, its
turnover times two times three times at least
I've never asked I
should start asking what
tells me is it a Snapfish listed
Snapfish or is there somehow always there
where you where you can further deduce
is presented okay to fit noted
I think that was it the  Americans the
big Americans are assembled like a
schotterfly well yes exactly I had
meat listed on the stock market but they are
huge I mean I think the power is 2
billion and CEWE makes 600
million or 700 million in sales or
different business models
they can of course have all these
printers  attack them well because people
don't
print the pictures in these photo booths that much anymore, of
course the younger generation
does quite a lot directly online or
via the app, that means there's actually
a really good marker, but I think
you've got a feel for it  have
so now that's what have created value
is in the
hundreds of millions range that's
probably a safe bet
like I said I've never attempted to
sell it
should I go into the process
so I'm sure if you're
here now if  you now here announce i
am up improve i need a
partner for us exp
ension people will report that but
for you at the moment it's not an issue as I said
it makes me think it's about you that
's just a lot of fun when he
can decide for himself I
just always have when I think whenever
you think about it
you get someone in or not
you keep coming back to this
point I'm sitting at this table now
and I'm allowed to make a decision
and I just make this
decision as if Westermeier
or Rene Ruland would and then I stand too
and then it's made and it's done  it's
just a great feeling in the sense
of you can
take it no I have to do it again then I have to
ask my third question who then nods
and I think
that's where it's always with me,
so to speak, where I say no I'm
actually staying  I'd much rather work
independently with them, so that means yes,
I took over what was said and
somehow a lot of money
flowed in, so somehow there  s 29
million is a different
culture, because you can feel that they
have borrowed money, so to speak, and
obviously everything will always be good with
you  and Berlin
are totally different I think
that just hiring employees in
Munich is something different than
when you say okay,
completely different, completely different employees,
which doesn’t mean at all that one is
worse or better is
just different, there’s a lot more international
in  Berlin is no question and of course
it's the case that when you come from the
birthday company you
always pay attention to your costs I mean
that sounds funny but a
lot of things are still released by us
or something like that that's
just  so you have to somehow
pay attention to your costs and if you come now
which financed you previously sat
the money on everyone  Case looser,
so you definitely have a different
culture, I think, but
that when companies see that it is
now becoming profitable, it makes
such a company a lot of fun
, and the employees too, I think everyone
who has worked in the company has it
profitable is just something
cool if you then a so if you
know okay I can actually
carry myself and it also helps them it also
helps the employees
than at least that was always our
impression that our employees that something
cool if you there profitable  you are and
no no lousy you
do everything so how deeply do you look
down at something like that you draw freely
so from 50 € to 5000 € exactly depending on that
I actually still draw depending on
now in the phase where we are
April May relatively bad, so to speak  was where we
just said okay somehow hold
the cash together where we then
just started
canceling events or such big be  i the company because
we because i knew okay it will
go up again i draw everything
and then now i go a
bit higher again but then i am
already in it relatively deep i also think
many companies have it that way at
unique too  I also said that from
the day I was, I'm still the managing director, so to speak. I
also managed it operationally for six months
until we had a new managing director. We
always flew to Berlin on Wednesdays Thursdays, we took the
train and spent
two days in Berlin and I think  that
when you look at the bill
you get to know the company really well, I
rarely see what the company has seen
from how it operates and what death
tools it uses and how it can
do things like I could, so to speak,
I could at least always learn a lot from
badges from
Invoices and things like that in Berlin, too,
so to speak, I signed everything from the outset,
where does d actually come from?
a drive here, I mean, what's
already crazy, so
you don't have to do that you say I'm flying
to Berlin two days a week now,
then that gives me the
company again to use a lot of money
to buy it, that's what you would have
Yes, you could have saved yourself the
stress of the trip or, for example,
had organic growth, my wife says,
for example, yes, what is what, so you
have my divisions to
build up a really big company or something that
drives me, yes, I am lucky that
I wake up intrinsically  motivated
as I can actually do it you think
I might have
learned that back then at the Kaltwiese, so
you can really hit me the day before
and I wake up at 8
a.m. and I'm 99.9% highly
motivated  and I want to achieve something new, so to speak
,
if I knew exactly I don't know
when, but I would also like to pass this on to my children
, but I am, I believe that
what an entrepreneur has like
you why is my new
business model going because you just notice
okay what is going on is going on and in
the end it's a lot of fun
I think
sometimes I almost have
to pinch myself because I  think okay
how crazy it is that we as
entrepreneurs are so free and
are allowed to make such decisions is an
incredible privilege and I think if
you are still so successful or
if you are successful no matter how then
you will notice okay that really inspires you
and you  then you also have employees who
enjoy it and
drive me that drives me this whole ecosystem
drives me to be
better than the competition
drives me to go to new managing directors
and I know I can
annoy someone again but that drives me
totally that drives me from morning to
night I could because maxi I get
really euphoric and it's just
I love is
when you  understand you have noticed
you also have a relatively large family
meanwhile four children is
already a job is already a job
normally erm
yes she works four days a week we
already have that so that of
course we have help at home no
question you have to  you can also
say it, otherwise it won't work, of
course, but we make sure that
one of us is always at home in the evening and
is playing with the children, so to speak
, doing and putting them to bed and
the other one is then allowed to work,
mostly the work is yes  or can
do sports or of
course together but
at the end of the day you have the children so that
you can see them and everything related and on the
weekends I don’t actually work at all
anymore we stopped we of
course still work in these
Q4 these heavy days me  my clear
Black Friday Plex has Sunday and
when there is such an incredible volume on it,
you are already working on it in
production  en or check with the
developers that the systems are running and
so,
but we make sure that we have a really
good one, it just has to be super well
organized, so we are well organized,
one always takes one to
kindergarten, the other to school,
so we have someone who somehow  so
we have to sit in the evening Sunday evening my
wife doesn't have an appointment and we'll
go through the next week then we'll go through it
then we'll make a meal plan so we'll
look at
everything at home very very
procedurally logistics there at least for
all these processes, so to speak, that the
next week it works
but my wife I won't be there
like that I'll rather live during the week
but of course it doesn't work what
all has to be picked up does he do
sports the other one has school out then he
has a trip then he needs it
and this knows how awesome it is,
so I'm very curious where
the journey
will lead to, so who has the feeling if you  plus
it won't be the normal exit
somehow with two years of burnout and
then you're out and then
you say because not the supervisory board and daddy
felt keep looking so you
've somehow got 2 million in
sales maybe even more in it
maybe  even more if you
look at our competition because they have many
of them have a lot more and it is
also you can, as I said, we
can also do it again, we
also look at business models like that or just
say okay you now have software
skills  we don't, so to speak, with our
software core that plants somewhere else
because again around this
configuration software is
pretty good, so to speak, we can also make
far labels that already
have 25 in there where you
can control card calendars, so to speak, that
then runs via our software  for example,
such topics look at us so we
have that's not much above you if
m  opens your eyes then you first notice
you don't think so okay that suits us
but then take a look a little deeper and then
you think okay actually
that suits us really well and it's
actually a tough rotation so
we'll take a close look at what else we do
be able to do everything congratulations on the
development of the journey so far and
thank you for coming
thank you very much thank you it was great fun all
right ciao ciao
[music]